he continues to grow this year finished this
season at Northeastern last season and then
white from college to the National
Hockey League and now the number one
goenda just underway here at KeyBank Center
Middle stat across the line in the high slot
finds a cutter shot and hit the iron middle
stat with a perfect setup for Greenway yeah
this started all in the Buffalo end it was a
turnover from coov originally comes over the
Blue Line middle stat just going to kick this
out green you can see there beat Johansson
but just can't beat the post and this line has
been so good through two games for the Buffalo
Sabers almost beats him there just off the post as
Tyson joose will Retreat to Conor Clifton around
to Mattias samelson and an outlet pass as we are
back at five aside joose in transition moving in
Genson [Applause] [Music] [Applause] score
as you can see up top a quick change there
Watson's jumping on gurgenson finds that hole
and absolutely wires one top corner but what a
play here and Joe's good pass Chang gets him in
trouble gurgenson fires it and he gets his first
of the year Samson lost it to Hegel finds it again
off the half wall hoping for Tage Thompson not
past Victor Hedman another fluttering pass out in
front ah Save By by Levi right between the circles
a great look for Braden point and Levi robbed him
here comes tuck with speed tuck R bler save made
it the opposite end by Johansson Cho with a drop
pass Braden point with a spin move gave it away to
Skinner at the Buffalo line and now tuck gains the
Tampa end tuck behind the net Cent's a pass that's
off the skates a point right back to up up top
Power Shot pass down low Skinner SC first of the
air for the Top Line Roofing it is Jeff Skinner to
give Buffalo a two nothing lead what a pass from
Owen power the young dman look at the vision heads
up the entire way finds his team to Skinner he has
enough time to well that and he tucks this just
underneath the bar as Johansson can't get over
there in time but ow in power with an unreal
Vision to Skinner side of the net two nothing
Buffalo as Skinner is thrilled with that call is
cach holds in at the left point 45 seconds to go
on the opening period out in front braen Point
save by Levi and Dave Jackson our officiating
expert Key Bank Center here the home ICE of the
Sabers and they had a terrific first period but
two extra minutes given to Rasmus Dalene and it's
right back out Center Circle controlled by headman
Braden Point met at the Buffalo line it's on side
Boule to cucher off dangle shoots glove save made
by Deon Levi Z here you see COV he fakes the
shot here opens his blade pulls it across tries
it goes against seam but Levi flashes the leather
keeps this one to nothing little maneuver by tuck
and now Thompson swings it back to Skinner heo
drags and backpedals Skinner diagonal that shot
save made by Johansson as he robs Thompson
how did that pass from Skinner find its way
through all of that traffic tape to tape to Tage
Thompson what a pass and an even better stop from
Johansson to get all the way over and take away
that top half of the ice what a play from Buffalo
better stop Benson moves in Skinner on his right
shoots sa Johansson looks behind wasn't sure if
he had this one you could see him check behind
you but Benson he's looking see if the passing
Lane's not there I love his option there shoot
the puck get it on net before the year began and
it looks like that's going to be something that
will linger all the way through the year yeah
you know stepen stos you know said he mentioned
it before when the out in front score Hegel oh
Puck popped right in the slot and Hegel just BS it
behind Levi and the lead cut in half Tampa on the
board he go in the right spot see yoka har
there Jan's got the puck cell's battling
for it as well good 50/50 battle clion and Jano
sticks kind of just come together Pops that puck
out to haggle all by himself right in the slot
listed over Levi's glove Tampa Bay right back in
this [Music] [Applause] [Music] one third period
comeback win since the start of last season and
Brandon Hegel with his third of the Season gets
them on the board so we start the third period
with kucherov bringing it in slides one behind
the net clipon on the move out to Joost broken
up by Hedman and he one hands it right back into
Buffalo ice scretch pass aoso shoot Save Me by
Johanson look for uh for Tampa to make a push here
Theo Genson to Clifton all out there for over a
minute and trapped out there because of the icing
call there's coov tried to go high to the short
side and Levi was ready and it looks like this
one either gets a piece of Levi or no off the
bar I don't know if Levi gets ends up getting
a piece of this give a better chance from this
angle but COV grabs that puck off of Levi off of
the crossbar he looks to the sky he can't believe
it this game was almost 22 confidently along the
line and now pulls it back out to Center brayen
Point gains The Zone once again point to the half
wall serf the trailer rist shot carams Wide Bar
roule broke his stick on that deflection gets to
the bench serach walks in shoots save made with
the left pad by Levi another big stop from Levi
comes out pop of his paint makes himself look
big flashes his left pad out radish to Sherry
that shot blocked to the high glass in the far
Corner Clifton hoping for Skinner and inter by
radish not past tuck going short side pulling
it off the end wall with Skinner serach the back
hand pass braon Point lobs it in 15 seconds to go
Bren Point retrieves throws it towards the net
Levi makes the save and holds the left post for
the rebound as well it's out in front poke that
scar heel Taps it in 7 Seconds to go and we are
tied and now it's all about just winning
battles and trying to get pucks the net Point
tries the first time he doesn't succeed
he tries again heel with the original
tip there is some speed and
Talent on the ice right now
as cage Thompson controls to tuck
to begin overtime as Dalene toes
the Blue Line Jordon Greenway on the
move his cousins create space shoot
[Music] scar first win of the season for
the Buffalo Sabers as cousins ends it in
overtime cousins comes in KES the puck
from Greenway and it's going to be him
and sheeri oneon-one he pushes it wide Gets
Out Of sher's Reach and as he does that he
shoots Against the Grain Johansson's leaning
to his left and it takes a perfect shot off
of the post you can see him push it Out Of
sher's Reach and absolutely snapped that
one off the post bom huge win for Buffalo
Dylan cousins puts Tamp Bay Lightning to
bed cousins had 39 goals last season he
was looking for his first of this season
coming into tonight and he finds it in overtime
celebrates with the fans and the reaction from
the bench the extra point belongs to the
Buffalo Sabers as they win it in overtime